a nine-year-old chess prodigy hopes the
pandemic doesn't derail his dream of
becoming the world's youngest
Grandmaster we first met chess champion
tiny Ottawa me last year he and his
family were living in a New York City
homeless shelter after fleeing the
terror group Boko Haram in their home
country of Nigeria a lot has changed
since then that GTA has their remarkable
story of perseverance for now
tiny out of amis dream of becoming the
world's youngest Grand Master has come
to a stalemate why do you only have
three and a half years because I'm nine
the world record is 12 years of seven
ones so the longer we are on lockdown
and the longer this pandemic lasts the
shorter your time to be the world's
youngest Grandmaster but you still think
you can do it yes last year the then
third grader won in New York State Chess
Championship learning to play while
living in a Manhattan homeless shelter
tiny story of perseverance received
support from around the world the ottawa
me say they are truly touched by the
generosity within two weeks they rent
the house for us for a year it's a
purely miracle and they're committed to
pain that kindness forward the family
started a foundation that helps
immigrants struggling with homelessness
a struggle they know all too well
I really thank God I have a place to
live because it's not easy enduring
faith the family hopes can inspire
others they're sharing their story in a
new book titled my name is tani and I
believe in miracles
do you still believe in miracles yes
tell me why cuz I'm God as long as I'm I
signed in he always just here
god did wonder something me and my
family's life and there are more wonders
ahead for tiny comedian Trevor Noah is
developing a film based on his life
story how exciting is that I mean it's
very exciting when you got moving big
bite like made for you you don't just
use it I was okay fine and popular right
and then you you got spoiled that you
use it to like help yourself girl better
it's that humility that keeps him
grounded through difficulty and defeat
when you lose what is that feeling like
you don't actually lose you learn what
does that mean the meaning is that you
lost for a reason and you have to figure
that out do you think that people have
something to learn from your story yes
that never never give up always try your
best just keep playing on to the end so
your first move is what II for pawn to
e4 a lesson in a game of chess and in
the game of life you already knew my
moves before I knew them man if life is
really like chess I'm in trouble so
here's the book and though he is doing
some playing online during the shutdown
tawny told us he cannot wait to get back
to it for real real live tournaments
playing opponents face-to-face and
continuing that journey towards becoming
a grandmaster humbled by a nine-year-old
Vlad look what he said though it's like
I love his wisdom you don't actually
lose you learn that's a great philosophy
or I bled thanks very much